i don't know about you guys but i'm
personally sick and tired of boring
renders that's why today i want to show
you exactly how you can create this
beautiful render in no time at all
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we're going to be taking any
single project that you might have and
transferring it into twin motion
twin motion would be the basis of this
tutorial if it's something that you have
if it's not you can use any rendering
software the principles are the same
eventually once we export that photo out
of twin motion we take it into photoshop
and then finally we take it into
lightroom now i'm going to explain all
of these steps
very simply and very easily because this
tutorial
can be done by almost any level of skill
so without further ado let's turn around
to these two screens and get started
okay so you want to start by opening up
whatever project you plan on creating
this render with
i'm going to start with this realistic
project that is an actual project in
real life
but obviously it doesn't exist on a
beautiful floating lake surrounded by
the forest
to create this render in twin motion we
do need to create
a fake mountain around it just to really
simplify the process
if we don't then we're going to be
dragging trees up and down like crazy
and it just becomes too hard
so what i've done here in archicad 24 is
use the mesh tool to quickly create just
a mountain surrounding
the actual house itself so all it is is
a mesh
brought up and then i've created about
five meters of water underneath
it it doesn't matter what it is because
it will eventually be cropped out
so what we need to do is open up twin
motion by going twin motion
direct link and starting a new project
okay so we have twin motion 2020.2
open in front of us and it seems like
we're already halfway there
twin motion does most of the work for
you when you import from archicad or
anything else which is great
so what we want to start with is the
actual contents and the material
i'm going to try to run through this
tutorial very quickly but also give you
as much information as you possibly need
to know
we can see that the mountains behind us
are just big white rocks if we go into
our material library
come into ground nature and scroll to
the bottom
you're going to see uh midway through
mossy
rocks if we throw mossy rocks on top and
drag them all the way up
to about 10 scale we can see it starts
to create an almost mountain-like effect
it's not that important because they're
going to be absolutely covered with
trees very quickly down the bottom what
we want to do is change
that water from archicad straight to
actual water
from twin motion so when you start using
the c object it doesn't matter what
material you use from here you can use a
pool
the pool too the river the lake the sea
it doesn't matter we're going to be
photoshopping it out we also want to do
a little bit of work on the house to
make it easier for ourselves so
depending on what kind of render you do
you want to make the house still look
quite nice
so personally this is meant to be a
concrete house so we're going to go
poured concrete
scale it to 3 so we can see that's
roughly the size of a concrete panel
that would be a very challenging
concrete panel nonetheless it's okay
this is meant to have some sort of
materiality some sort of texture but it
doesn't really
and the sides of the walls are coming
out as well so i'm going to change the
size of the walls
metal with some brushed aluminium in the
dark black color
because it's also the window frames i
believe
and then we're going to change the rest
of the building into a dark
wood so we're going to rotate at 90
degrees
scale rotate
90 degrees and then change the color of
that wood
directly to black now it's again at the
end of the day this is your project you
can do whatever you want with it
it can be a completely different house
it can be a completely different color
scheme the concept is still going to
work exactly the same
we don't really have to touch too much
of the rest of the building because it's
pretty much set up
exactly how i want it what we do want to
do is make sure that the glass is
reflective
so we start getting the nature coming
around
and reflecting on that glass later on we
actually do that in photoshop
not in twin motion because twin motion
just isn't very good at showing good
glass
now the next step is creating the trees
and the forest that you see in the photo
there is a number of ways to do it you
can click like a madman with the trees
go into trees i'm using this colorado
tree for
this photo here you can use any tree
you'd like again
completely up to you so like i said you
can click like a madman and go to town
or you can go to context vegetation
paint
and drop that tree in so you can
actually
paint like a madman now painting these
trees on as you can see
scatters them quite far away and it
doesn't actually
make it very forest-like so in this
instance
i am going to click like a madman i'm
going to skip past this bit
and show you the completed project of me
clicking for like five minutes straight
okay and there we have it my finger is
very sore but
we have a forest surrounding our
building
now we may need a couple more we need
may need to change a few bits and pieces
but we're going to find that out when we
start setting up our
render scenes what we want to do before
we actually finish off and start
creating that render scene
is clicking a few of these trees at
absolute random
and then just increasing the age of
these trees so it isn't all identical we
do want to emphasize the rear row with
some aged
trees and some larger trees so we're
just going to scale them up
all the way to create the valley-like
effect
now i think i'm going to need a lot more
trees on this side but let's start by
setting up
our render what we want to do is find
the perfect spot for the house so we
click to create our first image
and we want to start somewhat close to
the house you can already see the house
reflecting on the water down here which
means we're going to have that much
of the image flipped over when we take
it into photoshop so that can be a
really good indicator for you guys
to know how much of the building to
showcase if you need to go back more if
you need to go closer
again that's completely up to you so
what we want to do
is line it up central or however you
want because this is your image that
you're rendering so
create it however you like try and
position it so
you're in line with the horizon you're
going to be able to figure it out pretty
quickly when you go
below the water level because we are
actually creating
a mirrored effect so what we want to do
is just line it up
perfectly i think that's just a little
bit off
so i'm going to try to line it up a
little bit better and
save that image there i personally don't
think these trees are all
the right size so i'm going to make a
couple of them bigger again
the one thing you do want to do is
create a secondary image looking
the opposite way the opposite way just
needs to be
a large amount of trees and nothing else
really
so we come back to the house and
create our second image of literally
just trees
you can either do it directly behind or
you can also do it
behind the actual house where you
already have hundreds of hundreds of
trees built
so completely up to you but you do need
a secondary image for the reflection of
the windows that i'm going to show you
in photoshop in just a minute
so we're going to create that second
image of just trees okay so now if we go
back to image one this is where it
becomes critical you want to set up
all of your settings perfectly so you
don't have to mess with it later
if you want to have it on instagram
change the format from full hd
more custom and change it to 4000 by
5000
that's the perfect instagram ratio for
now we're going to change that to full
hd
and we're going to do the same for image
2. the image already isn't perfect
there's a lot of lighting issues going
on so we want to try and create the best
lighting scenario possible
personally for me i always use perth
west australia because that's where i am
so i know where the settings are
you can use them however you want it's
completely up to you but i like to have
that golden sun coming through
so we're going to bring it up to an
earlier time
maybe august change that north point
so the sun definitely starts coming
through and
shining there we go that's really pretty
and we're gonna keep getting a little
bit on the left side there
okay so we've positioned it so the sun's
coming in nice and early it's nice and
golden
and we have some different textures
going on
the background doesn't really matter
because you can't see in this distance
and what we also want to do is change
the lighting
personally i think that lighting in twin
motion at the moment is just horribly
wrong
so we want to push the shadows to about
500 go to the settings
and this sun is cranked up way too high
i like to bring that down to about 5 000
and then you can see the scene change so
if we go back to our image and go back
to our location we have to just amend
that time
a little bit more so we get the lighting
correct
but it's not as harsh it's not as
overpowering and it doesn't absolutely
ruin your image anymore
okay so they're roughly the settings i'm
going to be using for this render now
and all we really have to do at this
point is export it and take it into
photoshop
so if you don't know how to export all
you have to do is come down to the
export button
click on the images and select all
and then click export okay so now that
our image is exported it is looking
fantastic and you could go ahead and
post something like this and it would
look great
but we want to take it to that absolute
next level and the way we do this
is relatively simple so the first thing
you want to do is replace the sky
number of ways to do that in photoshop
but the easiest way is edit
come down to sky replacement and it will
automatically
replace the sky for you it's fantastic
and it's super easy
i've used this gray sky by simply
googling gray sky
and importing it by going down here and
clicking the little plus sign
you can select any sky you want so if
you see i can click on this one
and it will change it this sky straight
away i can click on a nice beautiful
sunset
and it will change it to that you can go
through any
absolute sky you want import any sky you
want and
it will look a million dollars in two
clicks of a button then what you want to
do
is move the panel over a little bit so
you can see the edge of the trees play
with these sliders until you're happy
with the image quality itself personally
i like to shift the edge a little bit
play with the textures and the tones
just to make it seem a little bit more
natural if the sky isn't in the right
position for you you can just click and
move it
whilst that sky replacement software is
still open so
i probably personally want it somewhere
a bit there
or i think i've gone too far and lost
that little bit of sky there
and there we go i'm happy with that so
my sky replacement
is done now because we are flipping and
mirroring this image we want to
highlight everything
go ctrl e or command e whatever you're
working on
and group them into one image so now we
have our image but the windows are still
pretty average what we want to do is go
through and marquee every one of these
windows
to be able to mask over our image of
just trees
so we start by bringing in our tree
image
of just trees and painting it over top
i'm going to hide that layer for the
time being and zoom into my windows
i'm going to use my lasso tool to
outline every one of these windows
so i can cut in those trees in front of
this
so i'm going to speed through this part
again but it's literally just
clicking through and
selecting your window you want to make
sure that this
double square is clicked otherwise
you're not going to be able to
continuously keep going
so i'll see you guys in a second when
i've highlighted all of these windows
okay so now we have all of our windows
marked and that took a little while
but you want to make sure they are very
clean lines otherwise it just looks
sloppy
so we want to activate our tree layer
again
to be able to implement that reflection
so we turn on our tree layer and we can
still see
that we're cutting out all of those
trees there so what we do
is command copy well control command
whatever you're using and then control
shift v to make sure they paste in the
exact same place
now that definitely looks unrealistic we
want to reduce the opacity
quite far down to maybe about
or 18 if not even lower just so we get
that nice reflection coming through
now's the time we flip mirror and make
it look so much better
so once again very similar to how we did
it with the sky we're going to select
all the layers by holding
shift and clicking command e to reduce
them into one layer
i'm going to use my rulers to find the
absolute best flipping point so for me
it's probably about there
and then i'm going to use my polygonal
lasso which if you click and hold you
can find the polygonal lasso
and cut out the top part
of our image we want to go ctrl c
ctrl shift v and paste an
absolute replica of the top half we also
want to
marquee the bottom half and delete
the bottom half of our entire image
that's going to make a lot of sense in a
little minute we're going to take our
top layer our bottom layer whichever one
you want they're identical
flip them vertically and drag them down
to the bottom so now our image is
already starting to look a lot better
but we aren't just there just yet we
want to add
one more layer drag it to the bottom
come over to the paint bucket
and paint that layer black entirely
the last thing you have to do is come
over to your bottom layer and reduce the
opacity
to 50 that gives it the optical illusion
of that
mirrored black water okay so that's two
out of three steps completed and that
image is already looking
fantastic however there is one last step
that you can take
to make this image look so much better
and this step is completely optional
it's
up to you if you like that style or not
but personally i think it isn't there
just yet so what we're going to do is
highlight them all
merge them again go file save as
save it to our desktop as a png
we'll name it lake house now we're going
to take that image
in to lightroom okay okay so now we have
that image
imported into lightroom and there is a
million and one different ways you can
color grade any image
but i've gone ahead and created my own
presets specifically for twin motion
exports
if you want to download them and make
your life so much easier there's a link
down in the description
they're only about nine australian
dollars so they're very cheap they're
not very expensive but
they make images look so so much better
so on the side i've already imported all
my presets and there's a number of
different options we can
have a dark moody winter look or we can
have a more vibrant
autumn look personally i'm liking the
autumn external look for this image here
so i'm going to stick with that and it's
already if we just flick through
you can see a huge difference in that
color grading
so there's not too much more i really
want to change here i might use
the paint brush tool to just paint over
this sky a little bit because it's a
little bit
dark for me in my opinion and do the
same down the bottom
okay so i've painted over that much of
the sky and that much of the water
with the settings here on the right hand
side all i'm going to do is click
done and that image is completed
the lightroom section of this tutorial
is incredibly simple purely for the fact
that i've already set up my presets
and made them available for you guys as
well so if you do want to support me out
as a creator and as an architect
just simply download the presets and you
can create
something just as special as this in
absolutely no time
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below
if you have any questions for me please
leave a comment i do check them
very often and i try to reply to every
single person
i usually tend to just reply to the new
comments so don't bother re-replying
just
post another comment and i will get back
to you but until then i will see you
in the next one